Lake Constance is the biggest lake in
Germany and it shares it shows with
Austria and Switzerland the region is a
holiday paradise with a lot of small
little cities and a very diverse
landscape thanks to 360-degree imaging
you can explore leg contents all by
yourself by using the mouse on your
computer or your finger on your
smartphone you decide what you want to
see just click on the video and drag the
pictures where you want them if you're
using a computer please watch the video
by a Google Chrome if you have VR
glasses you can watch it in virtual
reality
[Music]
Constance is the biggest city on the
lake more than 85,000 people live here
the town still boasts many historical
buildings like the Cathedral
[Music]
very near of Constance you can find the
mine on an island full of flowers over 1
million visitors come here every year
the flower paradise was founded by the
noble Bennet family some family members
still live on the island and maintain
its huge gun
[Music]
the family lives in this castle my now
is open to the public all year round
the Italian flour and water staircase is
one of my highlights
depending on the season it glows and
different but always glorious colors
[Music]
right now is another Island and Lake
Constance vegetables are grown here in
2000 it was declared a UNESCO World
Heritage Site more because in addition
to tomatoes and cucumbers it's home to
three Romanesque churches
after the flower island of my now and
monastic island of Guyana the third in
the series is the island town of Linda
it's a perfect place to stroll and stop
for a bite to eat
[Music]
these prehistoric stilt houses from the
stone and bronze ages were built on and
in the water in untold ingen they were
given UNESCO World Heritage status in
2011
[Music]
in the reconstructed houses you can find
out a lot about the daily life of their
residents
[Music]
the small town of mayors book couldn't
be more picturesque it has half-timbered
houses cafes vineyards and a medieval
castle
one of Germany's most celebrated poets
Aneta font austere hoods off once lived
in it for a few years
[Music]
Lake Constance is a travel destination
that offers huge variety here you can
discover many things but the best is the
view over the lake
[Music]